red table talk started out as an
experiment on facebook watch and now it
has grown into an iconic brand and
part of the magic of the show is that
the red table is located in the middle
of will and jada smith's
spectacular lakeside estate only we were
invited to stop by
and celebrate with the ladies who made
the red table
solid gold put it all on the table or
the red table
do y'all realize that it was three years
ago almost to the date that red table
talk
started the table of passion the table
of truth
what has been your favorite moment of
this journey
the part about the whole process that i
cherish the most
is just getting to know the women in my
life
as the individual women that they are
that's kind of how
it started her asking mom you know i
want to know you
and not just you as my mother i was like
great
i got into a different kind of
entanglement
with august an entanglement there's been
so much healing
from marital entanglements to alcohol
and drug abuse and
most recently willow's polyamorous
lifestyle admission
nothing has been off the table for these
women i'm the only
polyamorous person and i have the least
sex
out of all of my friends and it is that
authenticity which has made red table
talk
a safe space stars want to come to did
you
sleep with tristan never people
have found this comfort zone though with
y'all how has that been i think jada
really sets the tone for that 100
but i tend to be um a little judgmental
and i don't know she's a boomer that's
what we love though because gary is
that's why i like the voice of the
audience
it's like child police
no i get that yeah i do appreciate how
you got after olivia jade
i do appreciate that oh my goodness you
know
games gonna come to the table real world
he's coming with all that fluff
new episodes premiere wednesdays on
facebook watch and here's an exclusive
first look at tomorrow's mother's day
show you know there's about to be
surprise after surprise there's people
hiding
all over the house willow meanwhile is
also following in both parents footsteps
by pursuing her musical career
she expresses herself with a completely
new sound in her just release single
transparent soul willow her musicianship
far exceeds i believe both her parents
i'm so proud of her
you've been doing it mama of course jada
used to be the front woman in the heavy
metal
band wicked wisdom when i first heard it
i was a little upset because i was like
how have you succeeded this quickly in
this game when it took me
years i heard everything you did the
smith family invited e.t to their
jaw-dropping 150 acre lakeside estate
red table talk is filmed inside their 25
000 square foot home where are we right
now because the background is
beautiful it looks like an oasis this is
gammy's island
island is right there that's gammy's
island and
her lake and this is her lake
yeah well that's what mr smith says so
yeah
he's the patriot he's a patriarch this
is my house
jada this is his dream he wanted all his
kids to be able to
live here forever because he you know he
grew up watching dallas
he wanted his own dallas the kids are
here every day
we all come here every day so this is
the family
compound center yeah the thought of
letting this place go just gives me
palpitations yeah because we thought
about it yeah
to them nobody else can have it like oh
we should downsize
no we're getting older and then gami and
will go